all these Department of educations all
these you know so many teachers I'm
hearing from realize this can help the
creativity to ask the question the
critical thinking that goes to asking
chat gbt is so powerful
but the archaic thinking the very basic
straight down the path to not realizing
that no four or five people on a board
or decision makers are going to stop
[__] technology you know the
Antiquated thinking that you have of the
way you grew up it's not going to stop I
just don't understand this [__] I'm so
pumped to see this headline because
every other headline or every other
conversation
in these the halls of Education
is so bad this is so bad we fear
technology and Technology just runs
right through US everything's bad and
then it's normalized enough
these kids are lucky to have this